here we go Gary I'm sending you over
sides for an audition it's a big role
finance type in deep mount Shu ting in
four weeks yes yes this is it your
British accent can you do that or I
think I can bloody do it okay great
amazing I love you so much Amy this is
that this is it oh ma go where's the
tube Lee where's a Julie bright lights
you sit here after mom died in front of
you you sit here like a piece of
from a gutter mum loved you she
treated you like a son which he most
certainly were not so I'll say this to
you once and only once before you rot in
prison you go to bloody how was
it
Wow that's the 47th time I've seen it it
keeps getting better dude
Daniel day-lewis could suck your dick
yeah man I really feel like this is my
Oscar moment you know what I mean if I
get nominated I'm gonna thank you first
obviously
Amy that everybody in Iowa then Leo and
Streep you know and they're gonna be
like who's this guy hetero cadet
Spielberg's like I got an old dude all
directed the Academy Awards I'm gonna be
so high on Molly I'm gonna make out with
Morgan Freeman he will not like that
then Michael Caine
I just want to say thanks man you were
there from day one part of this journey
into a realm well I don't know what I'm
even going okay don't go full Gandalf on
we had to save it for the room
you're a true Julie a lot of competition
in here is gossip on some dirty lollies
oh ah great gone ah man
knock it out what time is your flight
what's that from London I just flew in
so tired had a couple points on the
plane but I'll be all right
Oh welcome I'm from LA madness project
right you read it
fire pier fire I don't know one's
bratter about here the museums and
Lohner just planning away on the streets
you knows that the pub's prating in a
way it's gonna be good you leave it such
a small movie small movie small attitude
that's what that is so this is Gary
scales oh hi Gary hey we got so lucky
today we have our director here so what
I didn't I didn't know he's gonna be
here just came to her mother Tarantino
set this morning so turn to no yeah
because I guess yeah we're old friends
collaborators he'll uh he'll definitely
see this so it's good for you he's gonna
see it great so do you um get me
questions about what questions not the
script no should I have it I didn't
prepare questions I don't know even be
here so I was like you know I didn't do
discussions for Tarantino no just just
wonder if you had any thoughts with the
character you know you don't have to uh
Quentin punch the script up I thought I
thought that script was funny it made me
laugh which part made you laugh the part
with the cats when he jumps on the table
the ketchup set the window the cat
commits suicide
yeah the cat dies yeah and then the son
finds the mother's dead body and
yeah the cat jumps over the mother's
dead body and I just thought it was
funny I grew up with cats well let's get
started yeah yeah whenever you're ready
okay cool
what are you doing here mate at the pub
why are you here you know your mom's
dead you know let's do the British
accent oh yeah right yeah of course is
that too big let me do it again let me
try let me try it one more time Richard
let me try okay we're good
yes yeah you go to blah and you go to
blow head very interesting tank very
very interesting thank you thank you go
to boy yeah I thought we had our last
one hey how'd it go mate did you sign in
oh no I'm just me Gary well you have the
accent down there's nobody left want to
try oh no I'm good
I think actors are stupid except
for Gary I do like that attitude come on
in you have a good look already in
cereal oh yeah after after hot
hello y'all a bunch of bloody wankers
the whole lot yeah you this movie
sucks
yeah Rick that was great we're
gonna follow up with Davi job nah nah
dude Amy's not your manager whatever
dude who cares let's go get some cereal
so they said you were a tad green and
I'm a little tight and a bit loud but he
was nailing it at home yeah Rick saw it
I had it down dude right yeah but the
only thing that threw me was I didn't
know the director was gonna be there he
just surprised me I mean that's not cool
I mean I was thrown off okay well you're
gonna have to get used to that if you
want to book a job but Rick they were
very intrigued by you okay I know you
don't want to be an actor but I've
gotten such great feedback everyone the
casting producers directors photographer
Todd I'd like to submit you for
auditions okay as long as it works
around my video game schedule and weed
we can do that and coke let's not leave
that some time and Molly and that I mean
there's a myriad of drugs that Rick does
but also do you think that there's room
for him on our client list because we're
all going out you know we're doing our
thing and kind of in a groove does Rick
I hope he does but does he fit in no
it's fine I can make space you're not
gonna go in for the same stuff okay
he'll be the leading man right now I'm
like a second leading man right weird
friend awkward guy at the bar oh hey if
I book something I could pay for my own
cereal oh that's true oh dude let me
post this
you